let's talk about modoc because it's such
a wonderful wonderful show and you're
both
so so funny in it but what i wanna i'm
wondering is there's some very
shockingly emotional parts of this show
and i'm wondering
how you find that in your in your
performance when
you're sort of in the script surrounded
by all like people exploding and
extraterrestrials
how you find those human moments in your
performances it's like the golden ticket
that's the thing that i think everyone
always strives for
is how big and ridiculous and
vulgar and crass and crazy can we get
and then can we also
just be like really human and grounded
and full of heart right and it's
incredibly hard to do
um and so you know i think just from a
writing standpoint that that's like
always the goal and it's seldom achieved
um
and i thought the writers just knocked
it out of the park and it was
really there for me in the words um you
know
and and it's just fun to get to play
all of those levels like this show was
so satisfying in that respect
um because it was that made it so much
more fun to play
yeah and i think it's just trusting in
your captain i mean we
we we shoot in these booths without
getting to do them with each other
i got to do one with patton but for the
most part i did them by myself so you
just have to trust
jordan to say hey this is a really
heartfelt moment between
modoc and jody this is a breakup scene
and you just kind of go for it and
you're like
and then you start realizing as an actor
how much emotion you can actually
you can actually portray with just your
voice
and um and it's the first thing that
happens like they build the puppets we
see the puppets
but then it's really all jordan
directing us like a conductor right like
we each play our own
instrument whatever on the piano
melissa's the drums and
and should be like he'll be like more
drums or more you know
higher on the on the cello or whatever
so i feel like it's complete
faith in in our creators and just
knowing that if they're saying that
there's a galactic blast
that's going down and we need to be we
need to shout we shout and if he's like
look this is a really tender moment
between
two people who love each other but have
grown apart you just
dive into that and you're like all right
well i guess um
i guess this show can carry that emotion
as well
yeah i feel like acting is usually just
a lot of trust i feel like i've
interviewed a lot of people they're like
i just just
plea like i'm trusting you to make me
not look stupid like i will do whatever
you ask me to do
it is so much of that yeah
but you mentioned you see the puppets
and that sort of bit i'm wondering at
what point
do you get to see the show in action
like at one point do you get to see your
voice on top of
what's actually happening i mean
we recorded this yeah exactly we
recorded this over a year ago and i
just saw some of the finished episodes a
few weeks ago
um so yeah not um i feel like there was
one recording session towards the very
end
that i there had some very basic
preliminary
kind of stuff on a screen for me to see
to add some
like uh like
action little bits um
you know some like uh heavy breathing or
whatever
um and uh but yeah you you are
just like blindly trusting and and
relying on jordan a lot to describe
you know any visuals that you need to
inform your performance but
um it's a very cool process to see
especially
visiting stupid buddy and seeing the
workshop and the puppets and the sets
and
you know i keep saying this in all the
interviews but like
it literally makes my brain break like i
just i don't fully get it it's so
incredible the animation on the show um
the artists have are just mind-boggling
talents um so it's been a really cool
process and then to see the finished
product it's just like
it's like breakthrough technology which
is so
neat and it's never been seen before and
for marvel
to pick such a cool one-of-a-kind
uh format i think is is so neat like
they have the ability
to do the impossible with like you know
we've seen like these movies and
and these franchises and for them to
actually go more analog
where you have a team of artists making
the hair
making the clothes making the pants you
know building the
building the the small home i mean it's
like
it it really is i keep saying it's like
honey i shrunk the kids
it's like yeah you don't even realize
it's a small puppet until you see a
giant hand
come in but but like melissa said it's
really just voice performance
and it's not until i think we were
probably shooting the fight
recording the final episode that you
even get to see
any sort of uh things put together but
we were able to take a tour of the sets
and and see how they made the puppets
which
made you feel like you're part of a such
a big team and
you're like i don't want to mess this up
because they're putting their heart and
soul into this
one tiny button you know or this one
tiny rhinestone on melissa
and you don't want to you don't want to
mess it up so you want to just
you know be part of the team
and uh and hope it all works out in the
end
yeah i mean and i full disclosure i
really love the show and i think it did
work i think it did work out in the end
uh i was just talking to jordan about um
how bomb do you was that he didn't get
to layer in um
melissa's girlfriend and the fact that
she's bisexual because it's just this
really lovely note from the comics that
that didn't make its way over into the
show but he did mention that you know
should season two happen he would really
he would love to
to make that a part of it i'm wondering
how important that was to you and the
conversations that you kind of
conversation you had with jordan about
it
yeah well in a really like lovely
normalizing it way it he it wasn't
mentioned
to me at first while we were recording
um you know and i think a lot of the
focus of season one is on the family and
their sort of dynamics and
hopefully if we get to do more we'll get
to dive more into
you know the personal lives of
especially the kids
um because i think in season one we just
kind of more see them in the in the
space of the family
um so you know i
i think particularly when it comes to
superheroes
you know there's something so powerful
about representation in this fear um
because
of these sort of subconscious seeds that
you know watching these shows or movies
kind of implant in you you know i mean
as an adult i've gotten incredibly
emotional
seeing some of these female characters
like kick ass in these movies because i
didn't see that growing up
i mean you know that moment when all the
women like band together and like
is so powerful for women
like we just didn't have it um so
i think particularly and then in regards
to her sexuality
i you know we did a similar storyline on
brooklyn nine-nine with the rosa
character so i
got to experience firsthand how
meaningful that was
for i think it was the first time on
network television that a character said
i'm bisexual like just said the words
and i to see the impact that had on
people particularly young people
was just incredibly moving and you just
see the importance of it
so i'm so proud i was thrilled when
jordan told me that
you know they had planned to make
melissa bye and that it was in the
comics and if we get another season we
get to dive into that more
because particularly she's a teenager
you know and how confident
and and sure of herself she is you know
that's that could be a powerful thing
for a kid to see
you know to just be like oh i'm
there's i am completely fine like
you know i am who i am and there is
nothing wrong with that like so
you know that the thing about what we do
that um
really speaks to me and i feel that i
just always want to be like
in service of because stories can really
impact people in really deeply
meaningful personal ways so yeah i hope
we get to do more so we can dive into
that
yeah i i was i was telling jordan how i
just love the note that's
it's from the comics in the show how
it's like modoc is this this grand super
villain but having a bisexual daughter
not a big deal it does it doesn't even
doesn't even come up for him and i just
think that's a lovely character note
that i hope comes up for a season two
which i
i don't i it's not there's no season to
announce i'm wondering if there's
anything
you've heard or conversation you've had
about a hypothetical season two
i mean no we're just we're waiting
fingers crossed you know i mean
definitely
conversations with like jordan and
patton because i know that they
you know have a lot of vision and a lot
of ideas when it comes to this show
so there's you know we'll see hopefully
fingers crossed i feel like we work for
the cia
secret agent we're like yeah
you know like they don't tell us
anything you know until we need to know
they they run a tight ship over there at
marble oh yeah i've interviewed a lot of
people that work for marvel and it is
like doing
like government interviews like they
like i cannot tell you
yeah that my family will disappear
i i do i did find it interesting because
i was just talking to patton about you
know he's doing ap bio right
now which was brought back because of
sheer fan reaction
and that's something that both of you
know between lucifer and
and brooklyn i'm wondering what it's
like to sort of get that
concrete stamp of approval where it's
like the show's coming back
almost solely because people like wanted
it back so badly and i'm wondering how
that is for you behind the scenes to
hear that
uh well it's it's such a
it's such a treat i mean we were as you
mentioned
canceled and people from all over the
world
uh you know europe and mexico
and and australia and canada and india
and japan
and malaysia just started
voicing their opinion uh and and banding
together
and it was just such a cool thing to
know that people of all races and all
genders and all sexual orientation
and we have fans that go from eight to
eighty
eight seems a little young for our show
but you know teens around
and um and it
it was great i mean it was so nice
to have that like global embrace of
knowing that it wasn't like people
in corporate positions pushing for a
certain show
it was literally the people speaking and
voting
for a show that they felt uh represented
them
and made them feel less alone which and
inspires them which i think the best
media does it makes you feel like
we are all in this together and we're
not
islands and we're part of the human
community and so to me
um the best storytelling is really
brings people together and is very
inspiring so going to work after that i
i my heart was so full and especially
for me in particular i don't play like a
cool character like i'm not
an angel i'm not a demon i have no
celestial powers
i'm just a scientist and i would go to
these comic cons and girls would dress
up and cosplay my character
and have forensic gloves and have a
forensic jacket and have a forensic bun
and i was so tickled because these girls
weren't dressing up like
storm or they weren't dressing up like
you know a squirrel
like black widow they were dressing up
like
a scientist which is something that they
could become or they say
like melissa was saying media so
influential they said oh i'm gonna
major in biology now because of your
character i would have teachers say hey
i show clips of lucifer
of you in the lab because you make
science cool and you're a woman of color
in stem which i think is so neat so i
am i'm it's such a good feeling i bet
right melissa isn't it like
yeah i mean the world behind you when we
got canceled i don't think we
we didn't even know that many people
watched our show
like you know we kind of knew that we
were
embedded a little bit in pop culture but
we just always thought well a lot of
young people watch our show
and we have a lot of like memeable
moments
and gifts sort of moments on our show
and kind of thinking like that was it
and then when it just
blew up on twitter and all these people
came out saying that they loved brooklyn
we were just like what
yo lots of people watch our show like
um it was really like validating
and just inc we were just blown away
like so blown away and and similarly to
what you know amy was saying especially
playing this character i've had so many
especially latina women
just be like it is so refreshing to see
a latina character
who isn't spicy can't dance
like you know kind of bucks every like
stereotype and is smart
and professional and like capable and
it's not about her latina-ness
and so you know that
is also just like incredibly meaningful
and moving and you know sometimes you're
just like an actor plugging away in your
career and then you know you get these
moments where you're like oh sometimes
the characters we play really impact
people and they feel really seen and
it's important to note that and take a
moment
you know so yeah it's it's crazy
amazing well i can't think of a better
place and than there so thank you guys
thank you guys so much for talking about
the show
it truly is a delight i cannot believe a
modok show exists
but here it is and it's it's so lovingly
made and i appreciate that so
thanks for talking about it yeah thanks
have a good one thank you